le quartier de la gare de poissy devrait
à mieux respirer la ville a inauguré ce
mercredi 22 mai un puits de carbone le
premier des yvelines objectif de ce
dispositif lancé après deux ans
d'expérimentation lutter contre la
pollution atmosphérique et notamment le
co2 dégagées par les voitures
le principe est le principe de la
photosynthèse on prend de l'air vicié
que l'on injecte dans la colonne dans
cette colonne nous avons mis de l'eau et
des microalgues que nous éclairons on
continue et le fait de combiner les
clairement plus pollution d'un air vicié
les micro algues vont capter cet air
vicié se reproduire et purifier l'air
ainsi le totem de deux mètres cinquante
a été loué par la ville de poissy
jusqu'à l'année prochaine pour une
période de test coût total de
l'opération à 20000 euros la commune
espère également sensibiliser les
passants sur l'environnement
nous aimerions que les gens se posent la
question parce qu'un aspect pédagogique
qui est très important pour nous qu'il
se dise bah tiens il ya peut-être des
solutions au niveau du développement
durable au niveau de la défense de
l'environnement et qu'ils prennent
conscience de tous ces enjeux si
l'expérience est concluante sur cette
première année le puits de carbone
devrait être renouvelée à part la ville